hello and welcome to this video playing
poorly poorly b6 don't see that too
often the Owen defense or Owens defends
said oh no I have probably okay whatever
it is it's pison person called overnight
so M what to do and actually wanted to
template that right I probably could
click d5 anyway I'm sure he did it could
be looks very similar to some kind of
Sicilian sea freezes on
Wow let's play we move that's hard to
believe how does he not get out get
wiped out on the light squares that you
fall and so on again this is one of
those kids where it's pretty obvious
that this shouldn't work would you still
have to refute it with concrete moves
and they often don't manage
yeah I'm not really sure what he
actually plays I mean 97 I play Bishop
check night d7 takes takes Knight e5 and
e6 is just falling so this is this won't
work he cannot take I think taking looks
very strange takes takes Knight is seven
again the check 985 but yeah this one um
so here taking and to Bishop b5 check
should be right clop yeah probably he
had to probably had 297 i was there i
was i was just taking so here I mean he
will not take on d5 I think so I'm
canceling first and then think about
taking on your six andrew t 1
yeah i think ii for busy for b6 is
really pretty bad not as bad as this
position of course but I'm b6 almost 1am
play the leg and ce4 i 9003 put against
default before it's quite borderline so
let's see what he what he does is there
anything
mmm yeah it's probably not a bad idea to
muddy the waters a little bit so if I
take cream cakes it actually looks like
some activity in for him cheb g5 me go
for quick development
hmm Brooks III was a good move that is
they're definitely putting putting up
some resistance I don't know if I one
should think the way and I don't want to
take but it's probably still the best
choice Luke g8
how to do the sequencer for Maivia
keeping d5 potential efficiency 6 also
f4 it's now a bit more likely to be good
yeah f1 you cannot take a form rook
takes pawn takes rook you won't check
and a rookie invade
yeah I can take he write the kind of
cautious here play really some bad games
recently some kind of check twice it
rather check twice but it should be okay
and the book is hanging here on h4 check
check so now d 6 or what what's the
cleanest way of rope tricks here maybe
yes check
and there was a mid qualms ok left me
maybe more than once before yeah so that
was an opening opening disaster I think
it'd be sexist is really quite
questionable because you don't get
enough play against the center I'm not
sure he I think I think d 5 is a good
move here I think I've seen something
like that but if I had forgotten about
it I think this I saw this somewhere as
a dangerous sacrifice hip hip flex
position is looking weird probably quite
critical yeah okay let's not forget to
switch the zone yes III was a simpler
move and I think this this looks a
little bit like a Sicilian now c3
society probably not that bad i mean
it's it's somewhat better for white but
not terrible but this shouldn't work
really yeah and stop her she agrees that
doesn't work right Chuck zucchini seven
castles that was a pretty good try i
believe chicks okay in the engine is as
brutal as usual yeah probably opening it
up and me black black is not yet a
coordinated in any way if you would have
Bishop c5 quickly ok but don't don't
think air kak I don't think I made a big
mistake here with what I did engine is
quite okay with Charlie check
okay yeah so d6 didn't work and in
general I would really advise not to
play 1b6 against d4f why it just gives
way too much play in the center ok guys
thanks for watching